okay today I'm going to talk to you
about ecosystems an ecosystem is a
community of living things along with
all the nonliving things in an area
where they live an example of an
ecosystem could be a jungle
a woodland or even something as small as
a pond in fact the example that we're
going to look at today is of a pond so
here's just the lay of the water at the
top of the pond now the first term that
we're going to learn is the term
individual because what we're doing is
we're learning the different layers of
an ecosystem now an individual in an
ecosystem is a single organism such as
this little fish here so an organism is
the scientific term for a living thing
so as you can see there's just one
particular organism here one fish so
that is the very most basic level of the
ecosystem the individual what we're
going to do now is we're going to look
at the next level of the ecosystem which
is called a population now a population
is the total number of one particular
species within an ecosystem so as you
can see these fish are all the same
species right here a species all that it
means is a group of similar organisms
that are similar enough in order to be
able to reproduce to have fertile
offspring so as you can see this
population is just made of one
particular species so that's the next
layer of this ecosystem so if we have a
look at the next level the next level is
a community now what a community is is a
community is made of a few different
species of organisms so organisms of a
different species we're living within
this habitat a habitat is just a place
to live so let's say we've got a
different species of fish
and remember as well an organism is a
living thing o organism is a living
thing
but it's not just animals it could also
be plants so let's have a look at this
if I just do these Reed's here so as you
can see a community is all of the
organisms all of the living things
within a particular habitat this is
consisting of both animals and plants so
now we're just going to have a look at
the final level of an ecosystem which is
the whole ecosystem itself the complete
ecosystem is all the living things and
the nonliving things so if I was to just
draw a few rocks here because this is
the the nonliving parts of the ecosystem
as well maybe we've just got some some
of the ground here the water itself the
light the whole thing altogether
everything combined is the entire
ecosystem in this particular context the
ecosystem is the pond
so just to recap an individual organism
is just a single living thing a
population is made up of one particular
species it's the total number of one
particular species a community is all of
the different living things so all of
the different organisms within this
habitat and finally the ecosystem is all
the living things and the nonliving
things combined that is the introduction
to the ecosystems thank you